the history of the roman republic
is a cautionary tale
[Music]
we're going on a journey
that will teach us
a great many things about a free society
the roman republic was one of the finest
systems of government that the world has
ever known
the reason we should study the ancients
is because it makes us better human
beings
in the progressive modern world we want
to think that human beings can be
perfected
but really what history teaches us
is that we're the same people
if we as a free society think that we
are facing unusual tensions and events
we've got to understand
that there were mobs in rome
there was all kinds of trouble that they
were facing we don't have to be realm we
learned from the roman republic the
lessons of citizenship the lessons of
tyranny
and what it all means for a free society
to face difficult times particularly if
those difficult times
are a result of their own success the
histories are themselves a kind of moral
education a political education we as a
nation would be far better off if we
spent more of our time studying those
examples from roman history
why should you take the time to study
these old and complicated things
the answer is it's the best single thing
you can do
the study of the roman republic
is really one of the most important
things we can do as americans
our founders washington jefferson adams
madison
all study the roman republic as they
created the american republic it's very
important for us to understand why
this is our course on the roman republic
let's begin
[Music]